字幕: Aaron Jeung
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（松浦真）22歳の時 私はある
東証一部上場企業で働き始めました
そしてその私を 大きな出来事が迎えました
その会社では 私が入社する前から
不正会計が行われていたのです
その額 年間にして約50億
1,000名いた社員は 700人に減らされ
その後 会社は別の会社に買収され
そして今では 名前もなくなってしまいました
それは 10年前の出来事ですが
多分みなさん今年も
そのような会社があったことを
記憶にあるんではないでしょうか
「チャレンジ」っていう会社が —
名前がありましたけども
そういう風な出来事が 10年前も
そして今もあるということを考えていくと
その全ての企業の会社の中の人が
最初から悪いことをしようと思って
仕事をつくったわけではありません
その人達が 最初にこのような思いを
もってやろうと思っていた目的を
どんどん忘れていって
仕事の仕組みが固定化されていくことが
このような社会の仕組みが問題となっていく
原因の一つだと 私は考えています
良かれと思って 仕事の仕組みをつくる
社会の仕組みをつくる
それが逆に自分たちを苦しめていく
そういう未来を 私は子供たちに
残したくないと考えました
そして 25歳の時に
もし自分の身の回りで
理不尽な社会の仕組みやルールがあった時
それを乗り越えたり
変えていくための学び方を
遊びながら子供に伝えられるのは
ないのかと考えました
多分みなさんが 学校とか
大学とか社会で学ぶ時に
その理不尽なルールの仕組みを
変えていく方法を学んだ人は
多分いないと思うんです
そして生まれたのが
ミニフューチャーシティです
では 今からミニフューチャーシティの
説明を行います
（木村亮介）ミニフューチャーシティ
ミニフューチャーシティの主役は
デジタルネイティブなんて呼ばれている
今の現代の子供たちです
今 一昔前では想像もつかなかったような
ビジネスだとか 仕事っていうものが
どんどん生まれています
今の子供たち
彼らが一体 何を考えてどんな発想をして
そして どんな仕事を
生み出していくでしょうか？
ミニフューチャーシティでは
大人は一切 基本的には
意見やアイデアを言いません
子供たちが自由に考えて
そしてつくって 運営をしていく
そういうものになっています
ミニフューチャーシティの初めは
まずいくつかの店に分散します
子供たちは大体 100人ぐらい
そしてその店には iPad が置かれています
iPad です
もう一つ 私たちが開発した
小さな手のひらサイズの
この「リットコイン」というものがあります
これは何かと言いますと
街の中での仮想通貨として
もう一つ これは全ての子供たちが
持つんですけれども
参加する全ての子供たち —
全ての子供たちのIDとして機能するんです
各お店には それぞれ
道具だとか材料だとかが
置かれているんですけれども
子供たちはそこから レジが置かれて
コインがあっていきなりスタートです
何を作ろうか？　どんなお店にしようか？
どんな看板にしようか？と考えるんです
そして子供たちは
「ちょっと何か 道具が足りないぞ」
「材料が足りない」といった時に
素材屋さんに行きます
その時に このリットコインを使います
ミニフューチャーシティでは仮想通貨として
「ハッピー」という単位を使っています
ちょっと実演してみましょう
じゃあ 僕が子供です
今１ポイントというのを １ハッピー
何かを買いたい時に
お店の人と交渉するんです
じゃあ１ハッピーで
押すと光ります
（ピコン）
今ピコンといったら こんな風に
「今購入されました」
っていう風にできるんですね
この光に ちょっと仕掛けがあるんですが
ミニフューチャーシティの中には
レジの他には ATM というものがあります
ATM では自分のこのコインの残高が分かったり
他の人に送金ができたりするんです
あまりお金の使い方には
使い過ぎに要注意ですね
他に お店ではルールとして
30分働くことに
基本的にはなっているんですけども
「他の店に行きたいな」って思ったり
自分で何か新しいことを考えた
「こんな店を作りたい」っていう時には
ハローワークアプリというものがあります
そこへ行って同じようにピコンとやれば
登録ができるんですね
お店の名前はもちろん
自分で決めることができます
ちょっと複雑に見える作業なんですが
子供たちはミニフューチャーシティの中では
非常にスムーズに行います
これは「誰のコインなのか」っていうのを
アプリが瞬時に判断することが
できるからなんですね
だからこそ ミニフューチャーシティの中で
リットコインは水のように
インフラとして機能しているんです
子供たちは「どんなお店にしようか？」
はたまた「誰と何をしてみようか？」
そこに注力して活動することができるんです
こんな未来環境の中で
毎回すごく面白い子供が出てきますよね
松浦さん
（松浦）はい たくさん
面白い子供たちが生まれてきます
私たちはこれまで
10年間で 50回以上の街を
子供たちと一緒につくってきました
のべ参加者は２万名を超えています
その中で ある子供たちが
街を変化させるんですが
その子供たちを紹介する前に
ちょっとここでみなさんに
一つキーワードをお伝えしたいと思います
「トリックスター」といいます
「トリックスター」という言葉
多分 みなさんあまり
聞き慣れないと思いますので
ちょっと説明したいと思います
「トリックスター」というのは
場を掻き乱しながら
新しい価値を生み出す人のことをいいます
子供たちは その場を掻き乱しつつ
新しい価値を生み出す中で
どんどん街を変化させていくんですね
しかし そのトリックスターの子供たちも
実際の社会では
「協調性がない 」「落ち着きがない」
「一つのことに集中しすぎだ」
っていう風に言われて
どんどん排除されてしまうことが多いんです
では 実際にミニフューチャーシティでは
どんなトリックスターの子供たちが
街を変化させていったのか
その事例を２つ紹介します
１つ目がこの徳島の隣にある
高知県土佐町で行われた
ミニフューチャーシティです
そこに参加してくれた写真にあります J 君
彼は小学校５年生なんですが
彼は未来演劇屋を起業しました
この未来演劇屋に起業する J 君は
初めてミニフューチャーシティに参加して
最初の仕事を終えた後に 他店を見回した時に
仕事を終えた後の子供たちが
あんまり憩いの場所がなかったりとか
リラックスする空間がないなっていうことで
演劇屋を作ったら
みんなもっと和んだりリラックスしたり
できるんじゃないかと考えて
未来演劇屋を起業しました
彼は一人で起業したので
最初は演劇をするにも一人です
しかしその思いに共感した仲間が
子供たちからたくさん集まって
最終的には たくさんの
子供たちと一緒に演劇をして
大人の参加者もたくさん見に来てくれて
途中からの起業だったにも関わらず
このミニフューチャーシティの中で
一番の売り上げを稼ぐことができました
しかしそんな彼も
その当日一緒におられた
保護者のお母さんから聞いたんですが
この土佐町から別の学校に転校して
その学校では 自分の思いとか
やりたいことが強すぎて
学校の先生とか友達とも
中々うまく折り合いがつかず
学校に行かなかった時期も
あったと聞いています
しかし彼は ミニフューチャーシティの中で
自分のやりたいことを追及して周りを巻き込み
そして新たな仕事を生み出して
どんどん街を変化させていきました
そういう風な部分も 彼らにはあるのです
もう１つの事例 ２つ目です
これは大阪のグランフロントで行われた
ミニフューチャーシティです
そこに参加してくれた
小学校４年生の K 君は
この街に初めて参加した子だったんですが
お昼終わって残り１時間半くらいの時に
この街には銀行がないんだ
僕は起業するんだっていうことを
突然言い始めました
実はこのミニフューチャーシティの
リットコインの仕組みは
全て iPad の中にシステムが入っているので
わざわざ給与計算する必要がありません
自動的に コインにお金が貯まります
しかし彼は銀行を作ろうとしました
「なぜか？」というと
彼は新しく宝くじ屋を作って
みんなに当選してもらって
もっと街を活性化させたいと考えたそうです
それで起業した後
銀行でたくさんのお金を集めるために
いろんな人に話しかけました
結果として とてもたくさんのお金を集めて
とても高い当選金を当てられる
宝くじを作ったんですね
しかし その当選金が全然当たらないんです
で 彼自体はすごくお金をたくさん集めたのに
全然払われないので
投資した子供たちからは
「おい どうなってんだ」という風になって
詐欺師扱いされ始めました
でも結果として 彼は時間が足りなくて
詐欺師扱いされたりとかしながら
すごい大変だったんですけれども
その後大人が ちょっと
「何でそんなことしたの？」とか
「その銀行をどうやろうとしていたの？」
って後で実は話を聞くと
宝くじ屋は一つの手段だった
という風に聞いています
なぜかというと 彼はお金を集めて
「街で起業をする人でお金がない人に
もっと自分からお金を渡していきたい」と
思ったというのが
本当にしたかったことらしいんです
彼は 友達からは時間が足りなくて
詐欺師扱いされましたが
もしかすると
未来のベンチャーキャピタリスト
渋沢栄一のようになっていたかもしれません
つまり子供たちにとって
新しい価値を生み出す時に
善とか悪とかじゃなくて
何かこれがしたいということが
子供たちは純粋にできるわけなんです
その力を持つ子供たちを
「トリックスター」と私は呼んでいます
でも一つ考えてみてください
さっき不正会計の話を私しましたよね
あれはある意味
法の抜け穴から新しい価値を
生み出そうとする一つの行動かもしれません
しかし その不正行為は
自分たちにとって
良い価値だけしか考えていません
では社会性を持ちながら
ある一定の社会性を持ちながら
新しい価値を生み出すには
どうしたらいいんでしょうか？
その時にこのミニフューチャーシティには
ミニフューチャーシティならではの
新しい仕組みがあります
それが 大人から子供たちへの
関わり合いの中に また含まれているので
そこについて説明します
（木村）ミニフューチャーシティでは
子供たちのリットコインを使った
データ・記録というものは全て
ログとして残るわけです
今映っているように 大きなスクリーンで
子供たちの行動というものを
グラフでお見せするんですね
子供たちは 自分たちのお店が
どこが一番儲かっているのか
どこが一番いいねを獲得できたか
っていうことを見ることができるんです
また子供たちは ID —
さっきのリットコインというものは
IDとして機能しますので —
下の図だと 真ん中で青色が
ドーンと長くなっていますよね
これは男の子に
一番人気があったお店なんです
こんな風に記録として残ったものを
俯瞰的に 子供たちは見て
自分たちのこれからの行動に移すことができる
トリックスターの子供たちは
街を全体的に見て
「あ 儲けるだけじゃいけないんだ
もっといいねを獲得した方がいいな」
っていうことだとか
これは２回押すと いいねができるんですね
「もっとみんなが住みよい街にするには
どんな街にしていったらいいのかな？」
自分は どんな行動を
したらいいのかということを
データを見て考えることができるんです
（松浦）そのトリックスターの子供たちは
こういうミニフューチャーシティにある
データを使って周りをあっと驚かしたり
自分がそのデータを向上させていくことを
とても得意にしている子供たちが多いんです
では ちょっとみなさんに
質問したいと思います
この中で子供の時
学校で落ち着きがないとか
協調性がないとか
一つのことに集中しすぎとかって
言われたことがある方 手を挙げてください
あっ いる　よかった
はい私もなんです
（木村）僕もです
（松浦）あっ よかった （笑）
多分たくさんの方が 学校の中で
いろんなことを言われたと思うんです
ちょっと学校のことを考えてみると
学校という場所には先生という人がいます
その先生が 例えば通知簿とか
内申点とかを良く書く子っていうのは
もちろん勉強できるって
いうとこもあると思うんですが
基本的に先生の言うことを
ちゃんとしっかり聞いて
その通りにできる子ですよね
で そうじゃない子たちは どんどん
学校の中から追いやられていくわけです
しかし学校という場所も
とても異質な空間だと思うんです
学校で 先生から良い評価をされて
点数が良かった子たちは
また良い学校を卒業して 良い大学に行って
例えばその子が教育学部とかに行って
また先生になるわけですね
多くの子が 教育学部から大学を出た後
先生になったりします
その先生がまた教える時には
また先生の言うことをよく聞く子供を評価する
っていう仕組みがずっとループしていきます
その中では トリックスターの役割を持つ
ちょっと逸脱して
よく分からない子供たちっていうのは
どんどん排除されていくわけですね
実は 社会を変えていく時に
そのような逸脱した子供たち
よく分からない人のことを
もっと受け入れていくことが
実は社会を変化させる
大きな要素になると思うんです
そして彼らの行動が
社会をまた新しく変化させる時の
鍵となると思うんです
そしてこのトリックスターの役割は
実は子供だけにあるわけではありません
全ての子供にもありますし
全ての大人にもあると思うんです
私たち大人も
「こうしてはいけない」
「こうあらないといけない」っていう思い込み
たくさん私たち持っていると思うんです
例えば今 TED で
今15分の期限を超えて喋り続ける
こういうこともある種
当たり前を壊していることだと思うんです
しかし それでもやってみるっていうことが
ある種トリックスターの
子供たちにとっても大事だし
私たちにとっても
大きな変化を生み出す
一歩なんではないでしょうか？
このお話を聞いてくださっているみなさんが
自分の中にあるトリックスターな部分
「こうしないといけない」って
いうものを一歩踏み出して
そして新しい変化を起こしていくと
社会はもし今 理不尽なルールや仕組みに
苦しんでいる人がいたとしても
それが変わって 新しい社会の
様子を見せると思うんです
ぜひこの話を聞いたみなさんと一緒に
もし理不尽な仕組みやルールに
今苦しんでいるんだとしたら
それを一歩変える自分の勇気を
トリックスターの子供たちから学んで
明日を変えていきたいと思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（木村）ありがとうございました
（拍手）
（木村）皆さんの街でも
ぜひミニフューチャーシティを
一緒に企画しましょう
（松浦）ありがとうございます
（拍手）